You are not a target. You are not
somebody's punching bag. You are not
somebody's outlet for all of their
frustration and their anger and their
insecurities that have been built up all
their life.
This episode is a little bit different
for the podcast one. It's very early on
a Saturday morning and I wanted to
record this so that I had the full day
with the kids. So, if it looks like my
face hasn't woken up yet, it's because
it hasn't. It's We're in the middle of
the book tour, which is going fantastic.
But I wanted to make time to tell you
what is on my heart. You ready? So, my
book has been out for a little over a
week now, and it's been fantastic.
Amazing. The book tour is going
wonderful. And as any new debut author,
I for good or for bad have been looking
at reviews online because you want to
know, are people going to like the book?
That's the whole you get very nervous.
are are you going to deliver on the
message? And the reviews have been so
kind and wonderful. And there was one
that hit me yesterday that I randomly
saw that I wanted to share with you.
It's very short. I know you can listen
to it. Just bear with me. I know you can
do it. Listen, you are not a target. I
was once told by my husband, you are an
easy target and everyone knows it. Time
and again, I walked away defeated even
with my children. Jefferson showed me
what I lacked was communication skills.
From his social media, I started
applying these answers to difficult
situations.
Let me be clear, this is not a book of
his social media quips. That's what I
thought it would be. No, it is learning
to understand where people are and to
adequately communicate with them. It's
teaching to deepen relationships by way
of strong communication skills. You are
not a weak person for purchasing this
book.
You are strong and courageous for
recognizing there is a better way to
bridge a gap, create healthy boundaries
that work, to not get sucked down a
rabbit hole, to not think you've lost
your mind. I highly recommend and I'm
starting my second read through. Kindle
edition is an easy read. Bless you,
Jefferson, for exhibiting love for
people.
I was just taking a back. I was totally
blown away by this. I have no clue who
this person is. In fact, they didn't
even leave their name. It just says
verified purchaser.
This is my point with this is I want you
to know where to go in your mind when
conflict comes your way. You are not a
target.
And if you felt like you've been your
whole life, this is where it stops. Rule
number one in my book, there are three
rules. It's rule number one, say it with
control. Number two, say it with
confidence. Number three, say it to
connect. And the whole focus of rule
number one is you can't say anything
about what I teach you. Whether it's my
phrases, my quips, my little words,
everything I I I can give you. None of
it matters if you do not say it with
control. If you do not first regulate
yourself. So, we're going to talk about
in this episode what I want you to think
about when conflict comes your way.
Anytime that somebody says something
that you weren't expecting,
your body naturally through its biology
reacts. People think that fight or
flight is something that has to happen
when you come with physical contact. No,
that's not true. It happens every day in
these little micro moments. Even when
somebody just flatly disagrees with you,
when somebody disagrees with your
opinion or they say something you don't
like or they call you an ugly name, your
body goes, "Hey brain, I I didn't like
that." And the brain goes, "Give me a
second." Yeah. No, we definitely didn't
like that. And it naturally reacts. You
have a scowl on your face. You want to
say something back. You get heated. Your
neck and jaw get tense. All biological,
all normal, all natural. So what do you
do with that? Rule number one in my book
is you use your breath
as the first word that you say. And the
reason why is because it adds distance
between what they say and how you
respond which gives you time to regulate
yourself to think of the quips that I
give you and the sentences I give you.
And it also mut the other benefit is it
allows the other person to calm down
theirs as well. Gives time for that
analytical side to take over. Every day
there are little things that tell your
body, I am threatened. Somebody cuts in
front of you in traffic, somebody
merges, somebody's riding on your
bumper, your body goes, I am threatened.
That's where road rage comes from. I
feel threatened in this environment.
When you're talking with your kids, when
somebody um says something to you that
they disagree with your opinion, they
dismiss your idea. You don't like that.
Your body's saying, "Hey, that feels
threatening to me. I want you to do
something for me right now." Now, if
you're driving, don't worry about it. If
you're walking on the treadmill, don't
worry about it. You can do it later. Do
it in your head with me right now. I
want you to think of
behavior that somebody does that really,
really upsets you. And we're going to
put a label on it. For example, maybe
it's disrespect,
dismissive,
condescending,
belittling,
rude. Whatever it is, make it yours.
What is a behavior that somebody
exhibits that really just just feels
like it sets you off? That just you just
explode when somebody does this to you.
You got it. You find that word.
Now, write it down. And right next to
it, I want you to write, "Does not
threaten me."
Does not threaten me. So the sentence
would be
dismissiveness does not threaten me.
Rude comments, back talk, insults do not
threaten me. This is the mindset I want
you to have when this kind of stuff
comes up in your life. Why? Because it
is telling your body of, hey, when
somebody raises their voice, that
doesn't threaten me. When somebody calls
me that, the way I'm reacting and
telling my body is, hey, this does not
threaten me. That's what you're doing
with your breath in that moment. That's
why we give it time to tell your body
what is happening in front of me is not
a threat, right? It's this idea that
um you you have you've seen the big
animals, whether it's a lion or an
elephant or something, they have like
some maybe a little dog or something. It
they just go, "What is this?" It's like
a a little animal coming up to a big
animal. They're not threatened in any
way. That's the whole mindset here of,
hey, what you're doing is this isn't
threatening to me. I'm seeing right
through it. Cool. I'm going to tell you
a quick story right now that um I
haven't I don't think I've ever shared.
This was I maybe three weeks ago or so.
And
where was I? I might I think I was in
San Diego airport. I was in the San
Diego airport. It may have been San
Diego. Everything's blurring blending
together at this moment and it's early.
Give me a break. Is I got through
security at TSA and went and I was
looking for my gate. Looking for my gate
and I kept following the signs and then
all of a sudden I was outside of it,
outside of the the security. The gate,
the terminal, it wasn't the terminal.
The gate was actually in a separate
terminal and I had just walked myself
all the way through. I had already gone
through security. I'd already gone
through all the the check and the
getting your stuff out and ready and
giving your ID. I had I started walking
out and I passed this exit where it
goes, you know, the point of no return
or has a red line there at the airport
and I walk out of it and all of a sudden
this is me by myself and I look and I go
I say this out loud. I go, "Oh my gosh,
I got to do this all over again.
because I have to know I'm going further
down where a separate terminal is. And I
say, "Oh my gosh, I had I got to do this
all over again." And a voice that I had
no clue where it was coming from. Female
voice goes, "That's why you should read
the sign, sir."
And I'm trying to find who that is. And
I turn and look. And as I'm looking, she
goes, "You have no one to blame but
yourself, sir. That's why we have signs.
I don't know if you're feeling this just
hearing it to me. Just the way the tone
came across
was so condescending and unexpected and
unnecessary. You ever had that?
That's why we have signs, sir. You have
no one to blame but yourself.
And I remember
being just taken aback. Uh, who who who
are you? And it was a TSA agent. Now, if
you're a TSA agent, I know not everybody
is rough and can be terrible. And I Hey,
I'm an attorney for crying out loud. Not
all attorneys are bad. There are some
TISA agents that are wonderful. There
are some people that are bad. We all
have bad apples in every profession.
This one right here, this lady, she was
middle-aged lady.
uh just looked so smug when soon as she
said that.
And this is what my my body wanted
to come back with some really good
zingers in that moment. I wanted to say
a few things to her because it was
really rude. It was condesc. It was
unnecessary.
And this is what I did. Of course, I
have to practice what I preach, right?
I gave it I looked at her for like 5
seconds trying to figure out, is this
did she say that? And I just give it
time.
And now she's sitting back and blinking
and looking at me. Her smile is gone.
And this is what I asked her. I said,
"How do you feel when you say that kind
of thing to someone?
Is it does it give you joy?"
That's what I said like verbatim.
And immediately
she got red like um uh and just got red
in the face and apologized right there.
I don't have to prompt anything. She
goes, "I'm I'm sorry. I'm sorry, sir.
You're you're right. That wasn't kind.
You're you're right, sir. I'm I'm sorry.
Yes, you you you can find the terminal
if you go straight down. And now she was
in helping mode. Now she was in helping
mode. You can go right here and this is
where it's going to be. I would say,
"Oh, well, thank you very much. I
appreciate that." All right. Well, you
have a wonderful day.
You are not a target. You are not
somebody's punching bag. You are not the
outlet for somebody to release all of
their frustrations and their angers and
their smuggness on you.
These tools work. This is why I talk
about them. That's why I feel so
passionate about sharing these.
You had the choice right in that moment
when somebody says something ugly when
they're the TSA agent in your life.
How are you going to react? What are you
going to say to that person?
Are you going to allow them to just
press your remote control and manipulate
all your emotions? I had a choice. You
have a choice. Is that going to ruin
your day? I just can't believe you'd say
that. Excuse me. Is that what Excuse me.
Are you talking to me? I You see how it
easily could go the other way? When you
give in to that fight or flight, when
you don't use your breath, when you
don't regulate yourself, if you do not
say things with control, it doesn't
matter
what kind of tip I can give you, it's
not going to work. It ain't going to
work. You have to say it with control.
You are not a target. I hope that this
is a good reminder for you wherever you
are. I can give you lots of tools and
tips on what to say and we have
different podcast episodes on that and
I'm going to continue to give you
podcast episodes on this
and I want to make sure that you know
and you hear and really the message is
very simple for today. You are not a
target. When that happens, I want you to
go to your breath, regulate yourself,
and then use the questions that I've
taught you. These are questions like,
"Did you mean did you mean for that to
be rude? Did you mean to insult me? Did
you mean for that to embarrass me?" Or
you give it time and then you ask
somebody a question of intent. How did
you expect me to react to that? I could
have said that to her. How did you want
me to respond to that? How does it make
you feel? Imagine being the person who
would say that to someone. These these
ways of responding to rude behavior that
is actually not a response. It's a
question. You're not giving them matters
of substance. I'm not saying let me you
you spit in my eye, let me spit back in
yours.
No, it is a reflection of their own
behavior and character.
And nine times out of ten the other
person sees that because they because
you're giving them time to are seeing
it's like uh the the blood the the red
it's not blood the red comes out of
their system you know somebody's seeing
red you have to give them time for that
to go away come back to normal come back
I know that's not who you are people are
not
people are far better than and we give
him a chance to be. Why? Because we know
that in ourselves. So when you have the
patience and the discipline to get to
that, you're going to have a better
communication and a better relationship
and a better life because of that. Cool.
All right. You are not a target. I hope
you have a wonderful day.
>> Where do we have to start to understand
this? Like I want to be a much better
conversationalist and I want to be a
much more effective communicator. I want
to argue less. I want to talk more. I
want to be heard more. This is probably
reflective of most people listening
right now. So if if if I was a a student
of yours coming in to be trained by you,
where is the first place you would start
with me?
>> Number one.
>> Yeah.
>> You say it with control.
>> Okay. What do you mean by that?
>> Yeah. So when you're in an argument with
somebody, what happens automatically is
your fight or flight starts to take
over. Even in a little argument, even in
the very, especially even in the small
ones, if I disagree with your opinion,
your fight orflight kicks in because
your body is saying, "Hey, I'm being
undermined." Your mind is telling you,
"Nah, I didn't like that." What he's
saying is different from what I'm
saying. You know what? We're going to
think of some other things that's going
to put that down. Immediately, what I
want to do is say something that is
going to fight. In other words, I'm
going to hurt you. I want to say
something that's going to cut you. I
want to say something that is hurtful.
Or we run from it. You ever had somebody
been on the phone and go, you know, I'm
over this. And they hang up.
>> Yeah.
>> Or they go, I'm out of here. You know
what? Forget this. And they go and slam
the door. That's their flight. That's
their they're leaving. It's I feel
threatened in this current moment by
this conflict, by this differing view.
So, I need to get out of it. When you
decide to say it with control, you make
sure that that doesn't happen. And it
all begins with your breath. All right?
That's the key. So, what I teach every
one of my clients is let your breath be
the first word that you say. So, we'll
run through it right now. That's cool.
All right. So,
>> let's do it uh an exaggerated one. And
what this is called and it takes
advantage of is a physiological sigh.
So, we're going to do is um two seconds
in through the nose,
one more at the top, and then go.
Yeah. Okay. How do you feel after you do
that?
>> Very relaxed.
>> Yeah. All right. Cool. So, what we're
going to do is get a shortcut to that
exact result.
This time, we're going to do it same
thing, but don't make the the noise.
One more. Stop
through the mouth again. Now, instead of
the mouth, only through the nose. Ready?
Now, that was a Now, we did that almost
a little. That was very intentional. So,
let's do it again, but like give it a
haircut. As if like you don't even
you're not even get me to notice. Ready?
>> That right there.
>> Now, that is your go-to whenever
somebody is telling you something that
you disagree with. That is your go-to
before you even say your first word
because it is going to make sure that
that fight or flight never kicks in. It
keeps that analytical side, that logical
side in it the whole time instead of
going, "Oh, wait. They can't yell at me
like that. No, no. That's that's a dumb
idea. Can you believe that? You say
instead of that, that's your fight or
flight. You never even gave yourself a
chance to breathe. When you breathe and
use that what I call a conversational
breath, now you it allows you to go,
"Huh, I wonder where this is coming
from. I wonder why they said it like
that." Now, it allows you to kind of
stay detached from that current moment
because you're injecting your breath
into it. When you allow yourself to
breathe, then it's going to keep you
much calmer. And so anytime I have a
client that maybe is getting a question
from an attorney that would be
triggering to them or upsetting to them,
it's always the training of use your
breath while they're asking the question
and start getting really curious as to
why they're asking that. What's the
point that they're trying to prove?
Don't look at the surface of the
question. Look at the intent behind it.
Where are they trying to take you?
Whenever I can teach them that, it's
it's a very powerful result. And to do
that I have to kind of be comfortable
with the fact that there will be a pause
between my response and
their question.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is quite uncomfortable for a lot
of people.
>> Yeah. You'd think but the more they do
it the better it becomes. In fact I like
it because it tells you that I actually
listened. So let's say for example ask
me ask me about my just say how was your
day Jefferson?
>> How was your day Jefferson?
>> It was good. It was good. My day was
great. Um you know it was it was a day.
Now ask me again.
>> How was your day Jefferson?
It was good. It was a good day. I liked
it. You see how one says, "I didn't even
think about what you asked me." The
other says, "No, I actually thought
about the question. I considered it and
then I chose my answer."
>> And so, you can do that even when
especially for leaders, they go into a
very busy work environment where there
are problems right on the floor. They
have to address this right at that
current moment.
The bad leaders will get very hectic and
rise to that same level of energy.
The great leaders will capture the calm
energy. They inject that breath and go,
"Okay, what's next?" Have you ever uh my
grandfather for example, I can ask him
um one time I was like, "Hey, do you
know where your your um your screwdriver
is?" And he goes,
"Yeah." I mean like you know what I
mean? Like
but I mean it just but there's something
about it where these kind of people in
your life that you're looking and drawn
to the calm energy, the anchors in your
relationship, in your conversations, the
people that just to be near them calms
you down. Just to be around them, you
go, "Okay, great. Steven's here. I I
feel better. Good. Okay, he's here. All
right. Things are going to go all
right." because they're looking for the
person who is going to be the lead not
just in the conversation but the
frequency of the room. It's a calm
energy that you have to capture.
>> When you took that pause when I asked
you how your day had been, two
interesting observations I had. The
first is
>> whatever you were about to say next, I
trusted more
>> because you had had some time to think
and you weren't just spewing out your
like automatic response. So I thought,
oh gosh, what's he going to say here?
And there was this element of like he's
really thinking. He's like, he really
cares about giving me the the honest
answer. And the second one is I was just
so much more intrigued,
>> right?
>> Because I could see you thinking. So I
thought this is going to be an
interesting response.
>> Yeah.
>> And that was all in that one second
where you took a breath.
>> You can see that a lot in interviews.
>> The person who you go, "Oh, this person
is smart."
>> Is when you ask them a regular interview
question and if they if they give a
breath before they answer,
>> you go, "Oh, they actually are are
listening to me." the ones that have
this rapid fire of let's say for example
and this uses another technique that
we'll talk about is if you were to say
would you bring some value do you think
you bring value to this company and if I
automatically said oh yeah yeah I mean I
think I think I would I think I'd bring
a lot of value to this company
>> versus
I'm confident I bring a lot of value to
this company
>> like you hear all of a sudden you go
that's that's my person heard me
considered it and I'm really curious
about what you're going to say next.
>> There was something is there something
in the contemplation which means that I
believe you checked.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it's a simple way to describe it in
that second example where you paused and
said, "Yeah, I bring a lot of value to
this company." I was like, "He actually
checked."
>> Exactly.
>> He like checked. He believes it. So I
believe it.
>> Right. And that's way every time I teach
a client and I'm preparing them uh for
their deposition, what they call a depo.
>> When you say a client, who do you mean?
You mean
>> Yeah. So, uh, people that hire me in my
law firm,
>> right?
>> Uh, and now that's translated to me
doing it on my phone and teaching
teaching people in my own membership is
I would say, okay, let your breath be
the first word. And once you do that,
you are going to be the other person's
going to go, oh man, they really listen
to my questions. The attorneys, we want
to get you. We want to get you in a
rapid fire. We want you to answer very
quickly. Even better is when you start
to step over my question, answer the
question that you think I'm already
going to ask. When you do that, that
means you're not listening. You're not
listening. But when I can get a client
to stop, breathe, and go, "Yeah, you
know what? That's not that's not fair."
I had a client, Elizabeth, who one time
when I was prepping her, I would kind of
I would act as the other attorney. So, I
do that often to help get them in,
simulate what's going to happen. I would
say, "All right, Miss Carson, come on. I
need you to answer this question."
That's true. It's fair to say, "You
didn't see that other car, did you?" and
I kind of start to push them. That gets
them really nervous, you know, oh my
gosh. And their nerves get up. It's
because they're not breathing. When
people start to shake, they're not
breathing. And so she didn't know what
to say and I'm prepping her. Come time
after I taught her about her breath.
Same question. Somebody said, and I knew
this attorney, I knew he was going to
ask that question. He said, "It's fair
to say you didn't see that of the car."
She took a breath.
She goes, "No, that's that's not fair to
say.
I mean, I just left it at that. I mean,
and he just couldn't really do anything
with it. But the bigger thing was it
gave her the confidence of saying, "No,
I listened. I see where you're going
with this. I'm not going to go there."
And so, and it it helps you navigate
and empower you really with the tools of
making sure you're always saying it with
control. Another part of saying with
control is slowing your words down.
When people talk really fast without
thinking about it, it gets us kind of
anxious. When somebody is talking
really, really fast, you're like, "Okay,
I'm trying to understand you." It's
harder. Uh, let's say, I mean, I like
hip-hop. I like rap music. If you listen
to somebody who's rapping really, really
fast and you can't understand a word
they're saying, you kind of like, "Okay,
I'm lost in this song. I like the beat.
That's great, but I can't understand
what you're saying." People
that slow their words down shows a lot
more effectiveness when you communicate.
So, let's illustrate this. I want you to
say quickly with some almost some
exasperation,
um,
I already told you I'm not going to do
that. Say that real quick.
>> I already told you I'm not going to do
that.
>> Say it louder.
>> I already told you I'm not going to do
that.
>> Perfect. Now, I want you to do is slow
it down. Slow it way down. Each word,
you don't have to have the disdain with
it.
>> Just slow it down. Say it again.
>> I already told you I'm not going to do
that.
>> Say it even slower.
>> I already told you I am not going to do
that.
>> Oh man, that's awesome. Yeah. So, you
see how without the emotion,
>> Yeah.
>> you sounded even more in control.
>> Somebody who goes, "I already told you
I'm not going to do that." says, "I have
maybe 5% control, but if I slow it down,
same thing." And I say, "I already told
you I'm not going to do that." Now, I
sound like I have 100% control. This is
the person you go, "Whoa, okay." They're
not moving off their spot. They're not
somebody who's I can't press their
buttons and control their emotions that
way.
>> What type of person struggles with this?
somebody who um would be
not aware of their emotions, not aware
of their triggers, somebody who just,
let's put it, has a lack of awareness of
certain things.
>> Does one's self-esteem and one's
insecurities play a role in this?
>> Yeah, I mean, they play a role with
anything. My counter to that is
we can overcome it. It's it's not your
self-esteem that's talking. It's the
words. The words do it for you. Have
people who have a hard time saying what
they want. It's the words that they need
to say. So, when somebody's having a
hard time with self-esteem, what I find
is all I need to do is get them to start
beginning their sentences with certain
words, and it's always a different
outcome. they just don't know how to
begin it.
So it's very curious on how like
somebody who rarely does people with
self-esteem issues say I need for
example they typically don't like to say
that because it feels too uh forward
somebody who has self-esteem issues will
typically begin with so you know maybe
like uh I was thinking this and you can
you can totally tell me if I'm wrong but
uh that's the kind of thing that you
typically hear. they're just using the
wrong words to begin their sentences.
You have to find words that push the
progress of the sentence. For example,
if someone says like all the time, I
mean, I when you said that, like it it
just really upset me.
>> That doesn't push the sentence forward.
If you trade out the word like for the
word because
I mean that just hurt because when you
said that that that hurt me. I'm pushing
the sentence forward rather than letting
it drag. And so it's just these little
bitty tweaks that one or two words make
a big big difference.
>> So that was the first point. You said
control.
>> Yeah, control. Say it with control.
>> Okay. Is there a second point?
>> Number two, say it with confidence.
>> Confidence. Okay. How do I say something
with confidence?
>> You have to first understand what it is.
And I don't mean that in like a woowoo
like setting. A lot of people come to me
and go, how do I have the confidence to
say this? I'm giving up the courage or
confidence to say that it's the wrong
way to look at it. Confidence is not
what you have before. Confidence is the
outcome. And you get to that by saying
things that are assertive. What I teach
is confidence is as assertive does. So
when you learn how to use your assertive
voice, the result is feeling confident.
Like if I were to tell you right now,
Stephen, I need you to feel sad. You
have a hard time feeling sad. If I said,
I need you to be afraid right now. Like,
I don't I mean, what what is there to be
afraid of? Like, you just can't conjure
that feeling. Now, if I for whatever
reason just gave you a elbow to the
chest, I mean, you'd be like upset,
right? You don't have to you don't have
to wonder what it's like to feel mad.
You're going to feel it. It's the same
with confidence. You can't just conjure
up the feeling of of confidence. You
only get it by doing assertive things.
And the people that are most confident
I find are the people that have done the
thing already. So they have already said
the assertive thing. They've already
used their voice because the more
assertive they are, the more confident
they're going to feel. That's the way it
works. So you do it, you find confidence
by using your assertive voice.
>> And what is my assertive voice? And how
is sort of an assertive voice different
to
like disrespecting someone? Um I've got
this graph. I think it's from taken from
your book.
>> Okay.
>> Which shows the sort of middle ground of
>> Yeah.
>> I'll put it on the screen for anyone
that can't see, but respecting others
sort of versus respecting yourself. And
in the middle there, you have your
assertive voice,
>> right?
>> What is my assertive voice?
>> It's a balance. It's a balance between
sounding almost passive and sounding
aggressive. Assertive says, "I'm willing
to be direct with you even in the face
of
it not going well, but I'm at least
going to give you my truth or I'm going
to say what I need to say without
sounding rude." Whenever you are direct
with someone, it's also very kind to
someone. If I were to tell you and prep
the sentence with, "Stephen, I'm going
to tell you this because I know you can
handle it." That's different than me
going, "Hey, look, this is, you know,
probably going to upset you." and and I
don't mean to upset you, but you just
let me know. Like that is a lot whole
lot harder. The assertive voice is I'm
going to be very direct. At the same
time, I'm going to say it with a sense
of this is doesn't have to do with me
trying to push my way. I'm just letting
you know where I stand. Like you don't
you don't have to always play nice.
That's not what I'm saying. There are
times when somebody says something
that's that's terrible to you. You don't
have to push back. You just can't be
pushed over. And so when you learn your
assertive voice, that's where you find
ways to speak your truth more easily and
more readily. So one of the first words
or the lessons of say it uh and using
your assertive voice is that every word
matters.
The number one culprit of that is the
word just.
We use the word just a lot. It's
probably one of my my weaknesses that I
have is using the word just in common
conversation. No problem. It's nobody
cares. But when it comes to having to
push a boundary, say something at work,
be a little bit more on your toes, just
has a way of making you sound hesitant.
The most common way we hear that is if
somebody goes maybe an email or a text,
hey, just wanted to check in with you.
Hey, do you have 5 seconds? Just wanted
to to touch base with you. It sounds
like you're hesitant as if like, I don't
really want to bother you. If you remove
the word just, now you're leaning into
it. So instead of I just want to check
in,
I wanted to check in with you. That's a
lot more forward, a lot more forward
progress rather than just using the word
just. But every little word matters.
You've had those texts where somebody
gives you like a whole paragraph. I
don't I don't know what how to respond
to this. What I teach is that the longer
your answer, the more questions you're
going to get, the longer that
conversation's going to go, the longer
the argument is going to go. So you have
to find ways to say more with less.
>> You have to find ways to say more with
less. So does the amount that I speak
have consequence.
>> Yes. There is this it's this idea of the
more words it takes to tell the truth,
the more it sounds like a lie. Like the
more you have to say to explain
something to me, the more I start to
assume you don't know what you're
talking about. And we have this way of
what they I guess they call it word
vomit where you just you talk a whole
lot. People get lost in your sentences.
And also when you choose to speak makes
a very big difference. Like have you
ever been one of those meetings
and there's always this one person that
has to throw in their two cents. They
always have to throw out their idea or
be the devil's advocate or have
something to say at every single issue
that gets brought up. Most of the time,
those are the people that are honestly
the least connected to what's actually
happening or at least part of the
conversation because they want you to
know how smart they are or how many
people they know. These are the same
people that name drop like every other
sentence. Uh the person that is like,
you know, oh, I was talking with Stephen
the other day. Oh, you know Stephen,
right? Oh, yeah. Great guy. Uh you know,
and they start to name drop just so you
know how many people that they know.
Insecurities are are very loud.
Confidence, on the other hand, is very
quiet. Insecure people have the the need
to say everything so that I sound more
believable. So, you'll know how much I
know and how smart I am. Confident
people have the urge to say nothing
because they have nothing nothing to
prove. Like, if you disagree with me on
something that I know to be true,
I I wouldn't be nearly as affected.
Let's say uh like we both have on a
black shirt. If if you were like, "Uh,
Jefferson, this a dumb purple shirt you
have on."
Okay. Like, I don't need to convince you
what I already know the color of my
shirt is. It's like, if you know that
about yourself, what you have internally
inside, you don't have the need, the
insecurity to prove it to everybody else
that they're wrong. The confidence is
very quiet. The people that are
typically the most looked to are the
people that say the least. They listen a
whole lot more.
Do people capitalize on on that? So if
if you're triggered by me saying that
you have a purple shirt on.
>> Mhm.
>> Have I got the power now? Because I can
like play you like a fiddle. If that's
you're so easily triggered by something
that's so obviously like provocation,
surely like I have the power over you
now, right?
>> No. I mean I mean the the people that
are not emotionally intelligent, the
people that don't have the emotional
awareness, yeah, you can you can press
their buttons and play them like a
fiddle. Because what they've done is
they've that would be like me giving you
the remote. Say, "Here, here's the
remote to my emotions. Go ahead, play
them. Press that button." Oh, yeah. Oh,
you made me angry. How how dare you?
>> Instead of handing out remote controls,
you get in the habit of giving out
manuals. And so, if you want to yell at
me and press my button,
and me to say, "You can't yell at me
like that." versus me handing you a
manual and go, "Hey, I heard you yell at
me. If you don't mind, go to page 72.
You can look on paragraph three. I don't
respond to that volume. Like you're
giving a whole different mind shift of
this is what I tolerate and this is what
I don't tolerate.
>> Do you have a lot of um people pleasers
coming to you? You
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. People pleasing is very hard and I
mean and the thing is you can you can
please people just make sure that you're
one of them. And that's the harder part
is I'm always people say I'm always
saying yes to things. I don't know how
to say no to things. I don't know where
to go with this. That's a whole lot
harder. Using your assertive voice is
helps with that in a lot of ways. And it
is about trying to
make sure that when you people please
with people, you have to find a way to
set a boundary that is going to protect
yourself. And that's that's easier said
than done. It's it's interesting being
um I started my first business when I
was my first proper business when I was
about 18 years old and when you're 18
years old and you're dealing with people
that are like double your age and you're
different because your skin color is a
little bit different. You have no
experience. You I reflect I was talking
to the guy that was cutting my hair
yesterday cuz he's a a young black man
starting in business and you were aware
that every conversation you're having to
some degree is a test.
>> Yeah. It's like a test of how much you
value yourself, how much you believe in
yourself, and how much you believe in
what you're building and what you're
saying. Like, and it's an interesting
way to think of life that like every
conversation is actually a test,
>> a test of your conviction. And then I
was just I was talking to my barber
about how I've changed over time and how
business has made me become more direct
and more assertive than I was when I was
18 years old because like I wouldn't
have survived in some of the rooms that
I'm in with like very eccentric
billionaires who have done this the 40
years before me
>> if if I didn't have that assertive voice
if I wasn't able to look them in the eye
and say with calmness and a slower pace
what I believe to be true. Um, it's so
interesting like just thinking about how
so much of our life is about developing
this ability to assert what we believe
without the just or the caveats or the
excuse.
>> Yeah. Where they also go into trouble is
when people what I see a lot are people
that over apologize. I I find that that
is big with people pleasers where they
say I'm sorry in every single sentence.
Hey, so sorry I'm just now getting back
to you. Sorry, I just now seeing this.
Oh, I can't come. I'm so sorry. like
they start to apologize for things that
are not a mistake. They apologize for
things that that are not errors.
>> And when you start to overapologize with
every little thing without you knowing
it, it's slowly drip by drip corroding
your sense of self-esteem, your sense of
self-worth.
It's you your self-worth is not tied to
how little of an inconvenience you can
make yourself. But I was saying it's so
sorry I I I don't mean to bother you. I
just have a quick question. Instead of
the over apologies, what I teach is use
words of gratitude.
So, instead of the um so so sorry I'm
late even though you were like one
minute late. Thank you for waiting on
me.
>> Or thank you giving let's say it's an
email. Thank you for giving me the the
time to think on this. Thank you for
giving me the time to reply.
>> Thank you for giving me the patience.
And you know what the other person is
going to think? I am patient. Well, yes,
I am. You're so welcome. Mhm.
>> I mean, you're you're using words of
gratitude to press that and that's a
whole lot easier than the problem of
people pleasers and that's just over
apologizing to just about everything or
they undercut their words or they say
like uh I hate to bother you but and
then they have to say what they need to
say. In this regard, what do the most
successful people in the world, the
leaders, the prime ministers, the
presidents, the CEOs
have in common
>> as it relates to the stuff we're talking
about right now?
>> So, you know what I'm saying? So, like,
are they are they assertive? Are they
people pleasers? Like, what do they have
in common here?
>> What I find that people are people, so
it's going to most often it's just going
to come down to to their personality.
But overall, your most effective leaders
find ways of taking a lot of ideas and
words and saying them very concisely.
The bigger leaders, they don't write
long emails.
>> Yeah, that is so true.
>> They don't write long texts.
>> Rich people don't even say hello and
kind regards on emails. They
just they literally they they send
emails like text messages.
>> Yeah. I have I have found in my own life
that the richer somebody is, they could
care less about an email signature.
they're not if they even have one and
they might give you two sentences maybe
I mean it's very very quick and to the
point um because it's either they really
don't have the time
>> it's not really that it's they they want
to have the appearance of being very
they're direct and they don't see that
as a an offense they don't see that as
an insult they see that as that is the
way that I'm going to operate they don't
write long emails they don't write them
in a way that's going hey uh just want
to put this on your plate And if if I'm
wrong about this, you can totally let me
know. And I have a question about this.
>> What's number three then? So you've
given me two.
>> Yeah, we say say it with say it with
control. Say it with confidence. And
three is say it to connect. These are
how do you have how do you have these
difficult conversations with somebody?
How do you find ways to say what you
need to say in one of the most difficult
times? That gives a lot of people
anxiety if they know they have to have a
difficult conversation even in weeks
ahead, especially the day ahead. They're
just dreading it.
>> Mhm. So, how do I say something to
connect?
>> Yeah. What you want to do is get really
curious about the other person, but not
just so much that there is a framework
that I'm I can even give you. So, we can
go a step further.
There is a frame and I call them
conversational frames. When to connect
with somebody, it is a fancy word. I
think connection can be overused at
times. Just means I say something that
you can understand and you acknowledge
me. That's all we're looking for.
Doesn't mean that everything's happy.
Doesn't mean that's a hallmark car. Like
I can connect with you and still be
upset at you. My dad would used to tell
me if I came if I disagree with
something, he'd say he would go, "You
don't have to like it. You just need to
understand it." I mean that that right
there was a great example of allowing me
to connect with him and giving me the
the space to disagree. If you were to
begin your sentence with I'm not asking
to change your mind or I don't need to
change your mind. It's almost like a
relief before you say the rest of what
you need to say. Now you're not in that
combative fight or flight of do I have
to defend myself at any time. So
connection is this way of setting up
conversations that is going to get you
more of what you want. We talked about
the frame. Here's how to do it. And this
is the most effective tool that you can
use for a difficult conversation. Number
one, you're going to begin with telling
them what you want to talk about. Number
two, you tell them, and this is the most
important, how you want to end the
conversation, what you want to walk away
from. And three, you get their buy in
into that conversational frame. This is
what it sounds like. Let's say this is I
need to come to you and talk about
something serious.
So, first I'm going to say what we need
to talk about. Stephen, I'd like to talk
with you about some comments you made at
last Thursday's meeting. Two, I'm going
to tell them how I want to walk away. It
sounds like and I want to walk away from
that conversation with the understanding
that's not going to happen again. Three,
I'm going to get their buy in. I'm going
to say, "That sound good?" You're going
to say, "Yeah, now you know exactly
where we're going. You know exactly what
we're going to talk about. You know when
that conversation's going to end and how
it's going to end." And now I have your
buy in. And it's like almost an
invisible contract when somebody goes,
"Yeah, that's good. We can talk about
that. They don't want to leave it. They
don't want to break their words. So they
they know that they're going to be stuck
in it.
>> Mhm. And then is there anything I need
to be aware of when I have that
difficult conversation with them so that
I don't so that I'm successful in
getting to that outcome?
>> Number one would be set the goal of
knowing where it's going to end. That
that is the hardest probably the biggest
downfall of the difficult conversation.
People expect them to go how they had it
in their head. They want the
conversation to happen just like they
had it while they were brushing their
teeth that morning or driving on the way
in to work. They're like, "Okay, I'm
going to say this." And then they're
going to say this. And you expect
everything to go just how you had it in
your head. But as soon as they say that
one thing you weren't expecting,
all of a sudden they disagree with you
and you go, "Wait, that's not how it's
supposed to be. They were they were
supposed to say this. They were supposed
to say I'm right. They're supposed to
say they're wrong." I mean, uh, how's
this going to go? And then it begins to
drown falter like that
>> cuz when we go into those sort of
difficult conversations whether it's
with a colleague or our spouse or
whoever it might be much of the
objective I think for some of us is to
is to win the conversation.
>> Yeah.
>> In whatever definition of winning one
might have. Is endeavoring to win a
conversation a good idea?
>> I teach that you never want to win an
argument. And this is why when you look
to win an argument, you will often lose
the relationship. Like if you set out to
only
prove people wrong, you might win the
point, but you will lose the person. You
know, being right doesn't keep you
company. Let's put it that way. When I
look at his arguments, there's only
something to win.
All I've won is really the first step to
to apologize. Typically, when you set
out to win it, because most arguments
aren't really won, it's just they're won
by forfeit. Somebody goes, I I'm over
this or you said it something that was
really hurtful that makes them say, I I
don't want to uh we're done. I don't
want to talk about this. An argument
eventually burns out. That's what
happens. But when you set out to win,
you will lose the relationship. Like if
you you and I are in an argument and I
say something that's really hurtful and
then you leave, you hang up the phone.
What have I won?
>> Yeah. I mean, what I I've I've won
awkward silence now when we pass each
other in the hall. I've I've won that
awkward feeling. Now I have to pick up
the phone and apologize. I still have to
find a way to probably work with you or
live with you. What have you proven?
When has ever you
go onto social media and disparage
somebody's political belief, ever change
their mind? Ever. There's been so many
arguments I've had with like my
girlfriend where I have quote unquote
won and I felt like
>> Yeah, you will.
>> Because I because she like she might
come to me and say, "Do you know what? I
understand your point and I'm I'm
sorry." And there's part of me that just
feels like And I it's it's because
I thought that's the outcome I was
looking for, but actually the outcome I
was look looking for was resolution. And
I actually love this person so much that
a concession was not like was actually
not I it's not what I wanted. I actually
wanted to be happy with them.
>> Yeah.
>> So I had to, you know, I was thinking of
so many some recent examples where my
girlfriend came to me and apologized for
something where we were like disagreeing
about it and I just felt like that
she apologized. It's hard to explain.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, no, it's not an
uncommon experience. Whenever you felt
like you had to always be right, that's
what we really want. We want the last
word. When you have the last word, you
are typically first up to apologize.
That's all you've that's all you bought
yourself. That's the that's your prize.
Congrats.
>> And when that happens, you find a way of
going, that's not really what I I
wanted. Why did I say that? That was
just that was just hubris. That was just
me. I just had a feeling of being right.
And sometimes we have that feeling of
when especially in terms of people that
are in charge of other people. Um we
expect others to do what we say. When
you're in work mode and you say I need
this done, people get it done. You set
the tone. You this is how we want to do
it. And sometimes we translate that into
our own romantic relationships.
>> Oh no. I said it needs to be this way.
So you know what you to do? You need to
do it this way. And it's a different
shift when you're doing something that's
romantic versus something that is you
have to be captain of the the ship. And
so whenever you're in those difficult
conversations, you only see them
something to win. You're going to have
our pro problem. What I teach is instead
of seeing arguments as something to win,
you see them as something to unravel.
Meaning what we want to do is pull my
way and then you pull it your way. And
it just makes it worse. Makes it worse.
We have to give up. And it's not until
that next conversation that we actually
try and care of what happened. I will
often tell someone, "Help me find the
knot. Help me find the knot." And what
I'm doing is encouraging them to say,
I'm not saying, "What's wrong with you?"
I'm not saying, "Can can you be any more
stupid?" I'm saying, "Help me find the
knot." It's a way of detaching the
issue, detaching the problem. Saying,
"This is something for us both to look
at. Help unravel where's the what am I
missing?" That phrase right there is
very very effective if you can just ask
them the question, 'What am I missing?
They will always tell you because most
likely it's not something that you're
focused on. You're only focused on what
you're saying. You're not focused on
what they're hearing. Big big
difference.
>> I have um two glasses on the floor here.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
try not to spill it.
>> Nice.
>> Time since I've been a waiter.
Um, so I have these two glasses of water
in front of me. What is I know there's
an analogy you have for having a good
effective conversation that can be
demonstrated with these two glasses of
water.
>> Yeah. So let's say that this glass right
here is all of my thoughts and knowledge
and your glass is all of your thoughts
and knowledge and not just what you
think now. These are things that you've
known throughout your entire life. So,
if I were to tell you something
about I want to get your thoughts, maybe
a political opinion or something that's
a religious belief. I'm talking like
deeply held beliefs that you grew up
with. That's what's in that cup right
there. When we go into a conversation
with someone,
often what we find is, especially if
it's like a stranger, that what I say in
our first conversation should convince
you automatically that if I were to take
all of my knowledge right here and I
pour it in, there should be no problem.
But what but what happens when I start
to pour into here?
It overflows. Meaning, you have no room.
you have no room for what I want to
share whatsoever. It's going to just
it's overflow. Instead, what you have to
find are ways to ask questions and get
really curious. Meaning, instead of me
pushing my point, instead of saying why
do you believe that, beginning your
question with why, I start to get really
curious about how did you come to
believe that? Where did you learn that?
When did this happen? ways that I get to
ask questions every day like I do as a
trial attorney to find ways of getting
to the issue of what's that deeply held
belief, where does it come from? Because
only then, let's go ahead and pour yours
into mine.
There you go. Perfect. And so it's only
then until you have space that I'm
asking questions whenever I ask
questions and you start to answer just a
little bit more and then you answer just
a little bit more to where you actually
have space to care at all to what I'm
going to tell you. Like you can't fill
I can't fill a glass that's already full
with new thoughts. It's not going to
happen. It's not until I can get you to
pour it all out till you'll ever be
receptive and have room for what I want
to share with you. So, that's the key in
difficult conversations that you have to
find ways to get really curious about
who's the person behind the words
because the person you see isn't the
person you're talking to. I might be
talking to Stephen right now, but there
are things that happen in your life that
you believe that happened long before I
ever talked to you. And we have this
hubris about us that we think that just
because I told you you should believe
something right at this moment, you're
going to automatically change your mind.
Minds don't get changed in one
conversation. They happen over a year of
a hundred conversations, a thousand
conversations before anybody will ever
be receptive to what you have to say.
>> So what's like a real world example of
this idea that you might not be talking
to Stephen, you might be talking to
something he's dealing with.
>> Yeah. So, let's put it in terms of I've
had a a client before. Uh, this doesn't
need to rephrase that. I had a
deposition before where I was talking to
a witness and he was a huge mountain of
a man. His name is Bobby L Prey. I'm
talking Steph. He was huge. His hands, I
mean, he just looked I looked like I was
physically deficient in every way next
to this guy. And it didn't matter what I
asked him, Stephen, he got mad at me. I
mean, I was asking him basic things
like, "Where were you where were you
born?" Okay. And where'd you where'd you
go next? And what happened next? And
every time he would just get angrier and
angrier and eventually
I had to ask him. I said, "Do you need a
break?" And he said, "No, but I got
something to say." And I thought I
thought he was about to just flip the
the table on me. He was just so furious.
And I asked him, well, once he even told
me, he said, "You you can cut all this
buddy buddy stuff." except he didn't say
stuff. And he said, "You, you lawyers,
you attorneys, you're the worst thing to
happen in this government. You're the
worst thing to happen. So, you can go on
and ask your stupid questions, but I
don't trust you as far as I can throw
you."
Well, instead of taking that bait, which
most people wanted to do, I asked them a
question. I said,
"What am I missing? What's what are you
struggling with right now in your in
your life? What's been your biggest
struggle?" and they have to ask my they
have to answer questions in a
deposition. And what I learned was that
he big Bobby L Prey, this huge guy had
just put his mother in a nursing home
and he was the only one to take care of
her. His dad had died. His brother was
off. And he had been getting letters for
months
about his mom and her home from lawyers
about foreclosing, making demands, debt
collection, all these things that he
just didn't understand. And so right
then in that moment, I represented
everything he knew about the law and
lawyers and everything else. And so the
person I saw was an aggressive mad
witness.
The person I was talking to was a
worried son and and we got to talk that
out and I helped him and it was a it
ended it ended wonderful. We ended
actually hugging. But every day you have
these micro moments of the person you
see is not the person you're talking to.
That the waitress that looks like she's
being rude and dismissive is actually
worried because she should have gotten
off two hours ago and her mom is still
keeping her kids. or you have somebody
who even in the workplace who seem like
they're a little bit short on their
their phone call with you.
Somebody who looks like they're
aggravated actually their day began
because you know he and his wife are
going through a divorce and they stayed
up all night arguing. Everybody has a
struggle that you can't see. They're
having a conversation in their head that
you were not invited to. And so when you
have the patience to try and understand
the person behind the words, that's
going to go a whole lot better for you.
And they'll feel that when you just want
to accept them for what they look like,
it's it's always different. Like when I
if I were to tell you you were wrong
about something
for me to change your mind like right
now, I most likely am not saying that
Steven's wrong. I'm saying your parents
are wrong. I'm saying a grandparents
wrong. something you grew up your whole
life was wrong. That camp you went to
growing up was all wrong. There's pieces
and identities that have all combined
into what you believe now. And we have
this horrible habit of thinking for some
reason that if I say it to you right in
this moment, it's all going to change
and you're going to just immediately
conform to what I want you to be.
>> Being triggered is a hallmark of that,
isn't it? being when we say oh god
they're like easily triggered it's
really you're scratching at an open
wound that might have been there many
years ago I was reflecting as you were
speaking about a particular friend that
I have who I remember a conversation
with him in the middle of the pandemic
where he like turned to me and said um
it's people that are young and healthy
that are ending up in the hospital beds
and I remember saying to him I was like
I was living in his house I was like
>> no I don't think that I think the NHS
website says it's people that are like
out of shape and slightly builder that
are ending up in hospital beds. And he
like was like really really triggered by
that
>> and I remember he's like a good friend
of mine. So we had a conversation about
it and we dug and dug and dug cuz we
like really good friends like why why is
it that all of us as like boys we know
in like the group chat when we're
bantering all we've got to do is say
like now you're wrong.
>> Wait one
>> one thing and it's like red mist.
>> Yeah. and we had like a really open
conversation about it over the really
over the last like year and a half and
he said um
when I was younger all of the teachers
thought I was stupid and also I then got
bullied on the playground because people
thought I was stupid and then I found
text messages from my grandmother to my
mom where they said I was stupid and
then I found on my report card they'd
basically written me off. So 30 years
later when we're having a conversation
just a trivial conversation about the
pandemic when I go no I don't think
that's right and I like pull up the
website and stuff
>> and he gets like sees the red mist as me
and him call it now
>> it all stems back 30 years to this
experience of on the playground. So
>> like you said it could be proving
proving someone wrong but in that case
it's actually like proving the bullies
right. It's proving all the people that
hurt him right and it's showing up 30
years later as this red mist. The story
ends with him going to a therapist and
speaking about it and he's resolved it
now to the extent to which he can where
now when he feels that feeling he's able
to point it he knows what it is and so
it doesn't make the decision
>> right knowing your trigger is one of the
biggest ways to defend against that to
know your trigger and it's funny how
just like your friend is telling you so
many things in everybody's life goes
back to the playground
>> like we can remember that thing that
that one kid said like right now that
you probably remember it. Somebody said
in high school
>> came straight to mind
>> and and it's it's been years years but
you remember it
>> and it lives with you for that long um
of just simply what they had said in
that moment that you've created that
identity that's that's a trigger
>> and if you tend to hit somebody with a
trigger it's different like you can
always it's very telling in the
courtroom when somebody takes a level
one conversation and they ratchet it up
to a level And it's very disportion
disproportionate and it tells you that
there's a conversation happening in
their head that you weren't invited to.
It tells you that something else is is
going on. And when you have the patience
and the discipline to find that person
rather than just
fighting the surface, it you will always
have a deeper connection with that other
person.
If you're dealing with someone in your
romantic relationship, at work, whatever
that is easily triggered in that regard,
what advice would you give to the person
dealing with that person who is like
continually easily triggered? They see
the red mist all the time. It's almost
impossible to talk to them because they
immediately just flip to 10.
>> Yeah.
>> They avoid the difficult conversation.
you feel now that you can't even have
that conversation with them because
they're immediately gonna gaslight you
or they're just going to go straight to
>> and they're gonna be flooded,
>> right?
>> You know that phrase that I've heard
before about like when the brain gets
flooded like they just get overwhelmed
in their
>> Yes.
>> What do you do with that kind of person?
You just curious or
>> Well, it's I don't want to just say
curious because I don't I think that
doesn't do it justice. One would be you
have to delay what you what they said
from when you respond. You have to add a
lot of distance there because if you
continue to engage and go why why can't
you talk about this? What's wrong with
you? That will only spiral it more. What
they're going to hear is something is
wrong with me. Something I am feeling is
bad. When in that moment their body is
fighting. Their body is going I feel
threatened. I feel anxious. I got to get
out of here. and it's happening in micro
minutes that you there's nothing you're
going to be able to say that's going to
help that trigger aside from you
allowing them the space to have it. So
that means you're going to find ways to
approach conversations
with that in mind. So one would be
adding distance and not addressing it in
that current conversation because
they're triggered. You don't want to do
that. You want to find it in the second
conversation. So in the first one, you
can easily end it with, "Hey, we can
drop it. Not a problem. We can talk
about it later." Because problems
happen, Stephen, when you try and push
people into having conversations on your
timeline. In other words, when they're
not ready. Ever had somebody come up to
you and go, "Hey, I need to talk to you
right now." And and you're like, "You
want to talk?" Like, that's the last
thing you're you're trying to control my
time. This is not what I want to talk
about right now, and I'm not ready for
this conversation. And that that causes
a big problem when somebody's trying to
push their timeline on you. You um we
can talk about ways to to deal with
that, but it is that's what happens. And
when you do it with somebody going,
"What's wrong with you? Let's talk about
why can't you talk about this right
now?" You're just pushing them into a
corner and you're making them harder. I
mean, you just they become hardened.
They'll totally shut off from you. Then
they're gone. Then they won't come back
for several days most likely. So when
you start to push on them, things are go
wrong. So that's when somebody's feeling
triggered. That second conversation,
that next conversation is the I like,
let's put a frame on it. I like to talk
about what we began talking on on last
Monday. And I I'm not trying to solve
anything. I just want to understand
where you're coming from so that I can
do better. Can we do that? like right
there. That's going to be a much better
way to set up and frame that difficult
conversation rather than going, "Hey, so
um I question for you. Uh what's up with
you?" Because something's something's
off. All right? Like that's the way that
it's going to you're going to trigger
them again.
>> How do you handle somebody that kind of
belittles you? They're like picking on
your weight or they're
>> constantly like, "Are you still single?"
Like, you know, like people like
especially people that you're close with
have a way of belittling you,
>> right?
>> What What do you do in those situations?
>> When somebody is belittling you or
giving you a insult, that hurtful
comment, you make them repeat it because
what they're hoping to do in that
belittling comment is get that reaction
out of you. and instead you find a way
to take all the fun out of it. So when
you ask them to repeat what they said,
you're not giving them that hit of
dopamine that they were expecting from
your reaction. They're not getting that
that response time from you. Instead,
you're delaying that gratification for
them. Then it's just not worth it. Then
it's just not fun. And so when you ask
them to repeat it to say, "I need you to
say that again."
>> I'm thinking of of like using this with
a couple people in my life.
>> Yeah. We need to role play this.
>> Sure.
>> Um I'm trying to think of a scenario
>> like you just said right there. Um
you're still single.
>> I need you to repeat that.
>> Yeah. You So exactly then I'm not going
to want to say that again because now
that spotlight is on me and then also
what you lead up with that is you ask
questions of intent. For example, did
you say that to hurt me?
And now it's this mirror that they feel
like why did why did I say that? Oh,
okay. And then they start to backtrack.
Then you don't have to say anything. But
if often I can just repeat what they
said. So if uh somebody says to you,
"Uh, oh, so you're still single?
I need you to say that again."
Most likely they're not going to say
that again. But if they do, then you can
even repeat what they said. I'm still
single. That's what you asked me. And
all of a sudden, they realize this isn't
fun. They're not going to ask that kind
of thing again.
>> Wow.
>> Or you just asked that question of did
you say that to embarrass me? Did you
say that to offend me? Oh, no, no, no,
no. I didn't say that. What I meant was
And all of a sudden they're backing away
because they know you're going to stand
your ground.
Wow.
This is like very eye opening because I
can see both situations where I need to
use it and I can see situations where I
probably say things and I'm thinking
particularly to my adult kids that
probably feels belittling. I I can think
about like our our daughter out in Los
Angeles and every time I see her, she's
wearing a piece of clothing that I don't
recognize. And so I think to myself and
oftenimes I will say, "Is that new?" And
I'm thinking in my mind,
where where do you get the money for
this? You know, like that kind of thing.
And then she's like, "Yeah, I thrifted
it." And there's this little tiff thing.
But if she were to say to me,
>> if she was to ask,
>> are you trying to embarrass me? Like
>> Exactly. Are are you trying to insinuate
something? Uh are you trying to say
something that you're not wanting to
tell me?
>> Because you're right. The question
is what I'm saying on the surface, but
what I'm actually accusing her of is not
being responsible with her money.
>> It's that mirror.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it takes away the power of their
insult.
>> Wow.
>> When you can take all the fun out of it,
you take all the oxygen out of their
room and they realize that they're not
going to be able to control you with
that reaction that they were hoping to
get from you.
>> Holy cow. How do you respond to
disrespect?
>> A lot of silence. So often if you just
wait 10 seconds
that you're going to add distance
between what they said and how you're
going to respond.
And that makes it very clear because
what they're wanting when somebody's
disrespectful is the same way with
belittling. They're wanting a reaction.
They're saying this to get something out
of you because in that moment they're
feeling something. Whether it's a fear,
an insecurity, whatever it is, you're
understanding you're not going to you're
not going to deliver on that same plane
that they are. You're not going to be on
that same level. So, if somebody says
something disrespectful, you give enough
silence to make sure that it's a little
awkward.
And then you're going to say something
to the effect of that's below
my standard for a response.
And then all of a sudden, they feel like
the dynamic has been flipped. that's
below my standard of respect.
Something as simple as that, all of a
sudden you're now making it clear that
what you just said was beneath me and I
don't respond to things that are beneath
me in that way. And so now you're taking
control of it. Now you're leaning into
it. What they thought was meant as a
disrespect, they're now understanding
that they're in the wrong place.
>> What do you do? I I I was with somebody
yesterday who had just visited their
mother and I said to her, you know,
like, "How did it go?" And she said,
"Well, it was fine, but it's my mother."
And the thing that drives me crazy is
she is extremely disrespectful
>> to anybody that is waiting on us at a
restaurant. Like, so much so that the
owner came over and said something to
her. What do you is there a way to
respond when someone else is throwing a
fit or is being disrespectful? You know
what I mean? Like somebody's getting
testy at the airport or and they're
they're with you. It's not a complete
stranger. Is there something that you
can say to somebody in that situation?
>> Depends how your relationship is with
that person. I would advise that whoever
they're disrespecting, you don't join in
it and you make it clear that that is
not your behavior. So, you're going to
be person that is kind to this person.
So, I've had it before. My grandfather
came with me to Walmart. It was a
terrible time. Uh, he was he was in a
bad mood and he was crotchitty to
everybody we talked to. But I was the
one that was Thank you so much for
helping us. I appreciate it. Thank you
so much being overly Hey, I understand.
Thank you. Making that eye contact with
this other person if this other person
is not having a good time.
>> And then you have that conversation. I
had to have that conversation with my
grandfather. And
>> how did you do that?
>> I had to put a boundary uh a very firm
boundary of if this is the way you're
going to talk to people. I can't come
with you.
>> If you don't change the tone in which
you're talking to people, papa, I can't
I can't come. And so it very was uh what
what what am I saying? You're not being
respectful to people. Yes, I am. I would
not be telling you this.
If you had been respectful to people and
and it's this having this this
conversation where they need to it's the
people you love and often you have to be
their their biggest mirror of protecting
them also for how other people see them.
And so I love my grandfather. I want
other people to love him. And that means
I also have to make sure that I need to
put I need to prepare him in a loving
way of being very direct. This is how
you're talking to people.
>> Has he changed?
>> He has.
>> We also just don't go to Walmart.
when someone is quote unquote attacking
me or saying nasty things about me that
I don't believe are true or maybe it's
just
>> I don't like their way they're saying it
and I don't want it to penetrate my
heart and my soul
>> and be reactive and defensive and rigid
and frustrated and all these things
>> when the when the when the brow goes
like the
>> Yeah. Exactly. One of the psychological
or therapeutic
uh strategies that I've learned is to
imagine
either a a field, an energetic field
around me
>> that I can see it, but then it bounces
off.
>> Okay.
>> The words, the intention, the energy, it
comes and then boink, it just goes
around me and
>> like water off a duck.
>> Feel like there's a Star Wars reference,
but Yes. Exactly. Right. Yeah. Or what
I'll do is I will separate the ego from
the self and I'll have the ego over here
next to me psychologically and an image
of it. The ego of me here
>> I say, "Oh, they're just speaking to the
ego."
>> Yeah. No attachment.
>> They're just They're speaking over here.
They're not actually speaking of me.
They might be looking at me, but it's
just redirecting right here. Right.
>> And oh, this doesn't affect me.
>> Yeah. They're talking about that guy.
>> Yeah. And I saw um I think I saw I think
it was Selma Hayek one time talking
about this
um she was giving example somewhere
online about how you know if someone
spoke to you really poorly in Spanish
and you don't speak Spanish you're not
going to get defensive right
>> you're just going to be like okay I have
no clue what this crazy person is saying
to me
>> um okay so just act like it's a
different language
>> there's just different ways of like
>> separating yourself
or the the potential pain.
>> Yes.
>> What have you learned
>> to support yourself psychologically and
emotionally and spiritually?
>> Yeah.
>> When this feeling of panic, stress comes
your way or when potential attacks come
your way emotionally.
>> So, very similar to yours, I in my mind
I visually have a trash can next to
>> Oh, okay.
>> All right. And I can see it. It's one of
those big huge gallon ones. is the black
>> shiny. It's you got it. Yeah.
>> And
I see what they're they're saying is
just a shoot. So I can see the words
coming
>> and I'm sipped
>> because the issue they're telling me is
not the real issue. And so if I hear
something that's
uh offensive, that's not nice. I just
Okay, that's trash. Let me just I'm just
I in my mind I grab it with my right
hand, lift up, and throw it. Wow. Like
that's that's what I'll do with my with
my thoughts.
>> And I'm sifting to where if they might
have led with something that was snarky,
which our inclination is to grab onto
that and send it back to it. Yeah. Send
it back and Oh, I just I got a good one
coming.
>> Instead, yeah, you got it. instead if I
throw that one away, if I just trash it
and then I found the one word that they
said at the very end towards the end and
that was that was the one word and then
if I focus on that word then it all
starts to kind of crumble but that's I
just imagine a trash can.
>> You talk a lot about how to respond to
toxic people or bullies.
What is the way as an adult
to deal with a toxic person or a bully?
>> When you're dealing with bullies, we all
know from growing up, it's these people
that have unmet needs.
>> From when they were growing up, same
thing in everyday workplace. When you're
dealing with somebody belittling you,
being rude, or condescending, when they
do that, what I want you to do is to ask
them a question. And it's a question
that they're not going to be used to.
And it is you're asking them to say it
again.
Whenever you ask them to repeat it, it's
something they were not number one, they
weren't expecting it.
>> Number two, they're not going to want to
do it because it the first effect is
gone. You you've already blown out the
candle. They don't want to have to
relight it. It's this idea of I already
said the bad thing. Oh, no. They didn't.
I didn't get the reaction what I wanted.
I didn't get that hit of dopamine. I
didn't get that that self gratification.
Instead, if you were say something ugly
as a bully or somebody who's being ugly
in the workplace and I say, I can you
catch Can you say that again? I didn't
catch all of that. Can you Can you
repeat that for me? It is not nearly as
fun for them. The second go around. And
whenever that happens, if they have the
guts, which they probably won't, but if
they have the guts to repeat it, then
you ask a question of intent. Like, did
you did you say that to embarrass me?
Did you say that to offend me? Did you
say that to make me upset? Did you want
that to hurt me? You can begin with, did
you? Or how did you expect me to respond
to that?
>> How did you feel when you when you said
that to me? These are things that again,
just like we talked about, you're not
catching it and throwing it back.
>> It hasn't even reached your doorstep
yet.
>> Because all you've done is just taking
that spotlight that was on you and just
go put it right back on them because
it's a mirror. That's all that's all
you're doing
>> whenever you do that. It's really good
because I was looking up statistics
prior to this and I knew that there was
a lot of I love a statistic although
these days who knows what's factor
fiction but true what the internet was
telling me which is always a dangerous
place to start is that for young people
today that there was a couple studies
done by Boys and Girls Club that like
48% of kids under 20 experience bullying
on a monthly basis which seemed like
>> reasonable maybe a lot. Then what
surprised me is the number of adults
that say that they get bullied, which is
more like 30 to 39% based on two
different studies.
>> That surprises you?
>> Yeah, I guess so. I I I can't imagine
uh using the word bully. Maybe
>> maybe that's it. M
>> maybe uh to me there's some usage of the
word bullying as an adult that feels
like uh you're almost giving them power.
Like you can't you can't bully me. You
could be ugly. You could be rude. Yeah.
You could be inappropriate. But why
would I label you? Because the way that
I visualize a bully is like somebody big
kind of angry lunch,
>> right? Like I don't know. I'm too old
for that now. Um but but then I saw how
people reacted to your videos about
adult bullying in the workplace
>> and it feels like a lot of people
>> feel like they are bullied frequently.
>> Have you found that?
>> I have. One would be
it's you and I probably do not live the
same life that they do.
>> Not for sure.
>> Let's put it that way. We're
entrepreneurs. We own our businesses.
>> A lot of people do not.
>> And they work for other companies and
peoples and hospitals and schools and
you name it. And they are part of that
structure and that infrastructure that
does not encourage,
>> let's say, growth.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> they know that the job they got, maybe
they work at a refinery, is a job
they're going to have for the rest of
their life. Nothing wrong with it, but
that's not to say that there are people
that that we can call bullies. They
might not steal your lunch money, but
they will steal your self-esteem if they
can.
>> There are people that you may not call a
bully, but they'll certainly boss you
around. There are people that they don't
care about your feelings. It's not a
punch to the face. It's a punch to the
ego. It's a punch to your to your
self-confidence. people have no problem
stealing that and taking that away from
you from condescending behavior. And
it's sometimes the people you're related
to, especially the people you're related
to that that makes it even harder.
>> And so I think the biggest response from
the bullying, which you you I agree. I
think that's a fair question of I
thought we were kind of over this. I
thought bullying was for was for the
kids.
>> Mhm.
>> Is that we're all the same
kids. We're just
>> taller. look older. We got hair in weird
places
>> or not,
>> you know. Or not. Or not. Do you do you
look great? There you go. I'm working on
the That's the thing. We're the same
exact people in high school. Rarely have
they changed there. Some have. College,
law school, wherever you went,
everybody's mostly the
>> the same person. And so,
>> so, so really we shouldn't be surprised
when there's bullying behavior in the
workplace because we're all kind of just
giant adult kids and people are
struggling with this every single day.
>> The world is one big high school.
>> Yeah.
>> One big high school. And it's from the
halves and have nots. who's the the
pretty
get ready with me in the morning popular
girls to the who let's go get our gains
and eat a dozen eggs while we work out
our calves you know I don't know so
>> nobody wants to see those from me you
could maybe
>> yeah you know I'm working on it u but
yeah it's it's it's all the same
spectrum
>> but there definitely is that segment of
people who would say yeah in some way I
am I feel bullied. I'm pushed around and
I I I don't feel good about it. And I
can tell you from the amount of people
that
>> um have been so wonderful and so kind
and have given the messages of
I have a bully at the workplace. I have
a a mother who pushes me around. I have
a sister-in-law who I don't want to have
to see. There's all kinds of behaviors
that are the unmet needs. And it's so
funny, Cody, to see that when we get
older, how much of that's resembled from
our parents?
>> How much resembles of that from the
people that we were around that we
didn't know when we were kids?
>> Yeah. You know, sometimes I think about
um you know, have you ever met somebody
who's just great at comebacks? Like
they're just like sometimes I think
remember that show Entourage back then?
I always liked Ari because people would
say terrible things to him. I think that
was right when we were in I think
>> we were in probably similar ages.
>> Yeah, that was right in the middle of
beginning college.
>> High school. I don't know.
>> I was I was probably older.
>> I don't know. How old are you?
>> I'm 37.
>> Okay. 38.
>> I'm 36. Never mind. Dang, I forgot. I'm
37.
>> I thought only us women do that. You
went older. See us women. I still feel
36, but I'm 38.
>> I don't I'm cool with getting old. So, I
never I always think um I have to scale
back.
>> Yeah. That's what I typically have to
do.
>> Um, well, I I remember watching
Entourage and how he would respond and
he would always have these amazing
comebacks and I was never that type of
human. I think like a lot of us, you
know, somebody says something really
terrible to you and you think in your
mind, I'm going to do all these things.
I'm going to say it back. What you
actually do instead is nothing. That's
usually what I do. I just like in my
head I'm saying everything and in person
I'm collapsing and not saying anything
very cute or smart back. And so I was
wondering when somebody comes at you
with an insult, how do you do quote
unquote comebacks as an adult?
>> You give it about five to eight seconds
of nothing.
>> I hate that.
>> They'll hate that.
>> I know. I know it feels uncomfortable to
you, but it is one of the most powerful
moves you can make when somebody's
insulting you. Where you lose is you
send the zingo rack back. So, let's say
you're at a three and they send you
something that puts you at a five. We
have a choice. Do I rise to the level of
it or do I keep it there? Because if you
rise to the level of it, then you just
justify them to go to a a level seven.
>> And it it ratches ratchets itself up to
where really the person who speaks
loses. They're the first up to
apologize. The that's all
>> like there's this unspoken rule of who
has to apologize first
>> in any relationship.
>> Yeah. uh or who's expected and it's
typically the person who spoke the last
because they're determined to say the
the worst thing because that's how they
win. They have to say the the mean
thing. They have to throw it right back.
So that's that's how they win the
argument. But insults in particular are
ones that when you give it five to seven
seconds of nothing,
>> it just lets those words fall. A lot of
the time that's all it takes because
they have to hear their own ugliness out
loud. They were hoping that you would
catch it, Cody. That's what they're
hoping. They're hoping you're going to
go and just send it right back to them.
And then when they get hurt, they're
going to go, "Oh, that hurt me. How dare
you?" Like that's what they're wanting.
So it allows them to play the victim.
>> Allows them to to to play that card. But
when you just let it go,
>> that's the biggest thing. You talked
about it earlier of this
whenever you can. It is a big power move
when you can clue into somebody that
what they say could not ever threaten
you.
>> It is such a move that doesn't matter
what you tell me. That's not a threat to
me. You want to raise your voice that
doesn't impress me.
>> It's it doesn't um impress me much. It
is it it doesn't matter. whatever it is
that they can't do anything with it. I
don't care what you tell me. It's not
going to threaten me. It's not going to
make me rise up. And that's the person
who's always controlled and the other
person will always look unreasonable.
>> Yeah, that is a real superpower. So,
okay. So, somebody says something ugly
to you, you pause 3 to 5 to 7 seconds,
something like that. And then what? What
if they come back?
>> Cool. So, when they insult you, number
one, I want you to give it five to seven
seconds and nothing. Number two, you're
going to ask a question of in uh intent
or outcome. What were you looking for
when you said that to me? A lot of the
times that that does nothing for them.
They're not going to do anything. They
they they just will stammer over
themselves. Number three, it doesn't
matter what they tell you or give you,
just walk away.
>> That's that ending part we were talking
about of just just let it go. There's
nothing that they can do with that
anymore. They call you names in hope
that you will say something worse.
>> That's generally what it what it is. But
they say that for for their own fight or
flight. When they call you a name, it's
because most of the time they're feeling
something that they want to cause you
pain.
>> They want that to hurt. Same thing with
somebody who's on the phone with you and
they go, "You know what? I'm out of
here. Click or I can't get me out of
here." And they leave the room. That's
their That's their flight. It's the same
thing. They they say it's like picking
up a I don't know, picking up a pen and
want to throw it at you.
>> Instead of an object, I'm using my
words. Same thing. I want the same exact
result, same intent.
>> When I'm in a conversation that I feel
like I'm
um it's getting away from me, let's say
that that could be a sales negotiation.
It could be a conversation with a
friend. You name it. Um, I feel like in
my case, most of the time it's speeding
up faster than I want it to. You talk
about this in rule one, number six is
control the pace. And as I listen to
you, I mean, you're very cognizant even
of your pace and the way that you
communicate even on the show today and
even in your content. You do you're
actually a little faster when you do the
content from your car than you are right
now on the show. You're even a pace
slower today than you are in your car.
So I watch that like tonality and
pacing. Yeah. Let's talk about that in a
conversation because with my when
emotions run high often times for me I
feel like the conversation is speeding
up where my my uh intellect is now not
quite as sharp as my emotions are
running if that makes any sense. So what
are strategies to control the pace and
what does that even mean?
>> Yeah I love that you picked up on that.
the anytime you are getting that fight
or flight and I know all of your
listeners highly educated they know
fight or flight whenever you're getting
emotionally flooded like that it is
that's why you're having trouble finding
your thoughts and connecting things and
that's why the quicker you get maybe
you've felt it where you you're either
nervous same thing when you're really
mad you might stammer and you might go
like no no no that that's not and you're
having trouble getting words out it's
because you're just flooded your
emotions are there you're logical and
analytical side is not. And so what I
teach every one of my clients before
they go cross-examination and I'm just
offering them up to the wolves is a
constant reminder of you control the
pace, not them. That means no matter how
fast somebody is peppering you with
questions, the conversation cannot
happen any faster than you respond. So,
whenever they ask you a question and you
give a rapid fire answer back or worse,
you start to step over their question
because you already see where it's
going. Bad things happen. You say things
you don't mean. You say things that are
not fully thought out. That's why even
in romantic relationships, all of a
sudden, you blurt something out and you
go, "Oh, I that's oh man, that's not
what I mean." And you you already knew
as soon as it came out of your mouth,
you put your foot in your mouth and you
messed up. It's because you weren't
controlling the pace. That means you
need to slow down your words and that
you need to leave space between what
they said and how you're going and when
you're going to respond. There's a
difference if you were to ask me
if if you said, "Hey, Jefferson, how was
your day?" And I said, "Good. It was
real good." I mean, it was it was it was
really good. Thanks. Versus, "Hey,
Jefferson, how was your day?" And I
said,
"It was good. It was a good day." Like
you can just hear the difference in
which one listened to the question,
which one thought about the answer,
which one makes the other person feel
acknowledged or heard. Same thing with
that's why rule number one is say with
control. If you go down and let's say
you're you're at work and all of a
sudden you go, "What's wrong? What
happened? What what's going on?" and you
all you're sensing and telling the other
person is you're grasping for control
versus you come in take a breath and
then you're saying all right what
happened give it to me like people are
looking like we said for those emotional
anchors so what I teach is let your
breath be the first word that you say
that's how you set the pace of a
conversation so where your first word
would be put a breath in its place and
what's that going to do is keep your
analytical side engaged and to where you
do not allow yourself emotionally to get
emotionally flooded. And the benefit
second benefit is neither does the other
person because now you are also
injecting the time and forcing them to
slow down. If you enjoyed that clip and
want to see the rest of the
conversation, you can click right here.
Or if you want to see the latest episode
of the Jefferson Fisher podcast, click
right here and I'll meet you